hi welcome to root access the show on
Google developers live about startups my
name is martin omander and i'm joined
here by dawn dodge longtime investor and
startup advocate well thanks for having
me back
all right so lots of good
lots of good viewer questions we'll go
into one specific question this episode
about pricing microwave Vlad I'm sorry
if I butchered your name asks what
should be the factors determining the
initial price of an app and if a
correction is needed what should be the
transition strategy to a lower or a
higher price point without upsetting
current or future potential customers
good question there's actually two
questions there so the first one is how
do you determine the initial price point
look at the competition and if you're
competing against a an entrenched
competitor then you want to price under
them so say 10 to 20 percent under the
entrenched competitor if there aren't
entrenched competitors then there are
alternatives like there might not be a
product or a service that is exactly
like yours but there's always an
alternative if there's a need there
they've figured out some way to solve
the problem maybe it's not as elegant as
your solution or as efficient as your
solution but there are ways to do it so
you have to look at how our users
solving the problem today and how much
are they paying to do that and if they
switch to your product or service how
much additional productivity or gains
are they getting so that they'll pay
perhaps pay more than the existing
solution so that's two ways to look at
how to price your product either against
the competition and come in a little
lower or against the alternatives that
may be inferior and price a little
higher
okay so then you get your initial price
and and pretty soon you'll discover that
you weren't spot on you will need to
change it what are the strategies for
four uses for going up or going down
good question my experience is it's
easier to go up in price than it is to
go down and really I thought it would be
the opposite everybody likes something
cheaper except the customers who already
paid for Oh
so if if you take your product out at a
price say $100 and customers pay $100
and you start getting customers but
you're not getting enough and then you
lower it to $75 well now you've
alienated all of those customers who
paid $100 they're going to be angry
you've disrupted the sort of value
proposition that you had going in so now
where are you versus the competition and
so you need to think very carefully
before lowering the price it's easier to
come into the market at a low price and
then raise the price higher and higher
the reason for that is that typically
when you raise the price you're giving
additional features so you're making the
product better you're making it scale
better you're making it faster you're
having additional features there's more
value there so customers are willing to
pay more money so in my experience it's
always easier to go up in price than it
is to go down hmm interesting about that
freemium there's a lot of talk about
freemium is is that the way to go to
have a free tier and the premium tier
yeah that's a great a great way to go
because the the idea behind freemium is
that if it's free you'll get a big user
base and lots of network effects and
feedback from users that are free and
that's okay and then you have a premium
set that's where the AMIA manned
freemium comes from the premium set of
features that they'll be willing to pay
for so that's it that's a great way to
go and and then that allows you to have
the free or low price option and the
higher priced premium option you can
also do that with no freemium model you
can just have a base product that's $100
and a advanced product that's a hundred
and fifty dollars and a pro product
that's 300 dollars so there are lots of
ways to do packaging and pricing and you
don't need to be tied down to any
particular model and you shouldn't be
too afraid to get it wrong because you
can change it writer
exactly great mokou Bay also brings up a
great question what about ads that would
be great then I don't have to charge any
of my users oh so an ad supported ad
supported model yeah ad supported model
was very very popular about ten years
ago five years ago lots of web kinds of
content companies we're viewing the
content was free and it was ad supported
or I started into one of those I crashed
and burned well it's a very good model
Google itself is ad supported mm-hmm so
Google is an ad supported model but ad
supported sort of assumes that you have
a huge audience lots and lots of page
views lots and lots of users because
when you do the math on how many page
views you need to make a million dollars
in revenue through ads it's billions of
page views it's significant so you have
to have a pretty significant audience to
make ad supported alone work well
remnant ads and typically you know
remnant ads or run of the house ads that
aren't that targeted those are the kinds
that sell for ten cents CPM Zoar
CPM means cost per thousand or you know
very low kinds of prices no one's gonna
make a lot of money doing that
conversely if you're using Google
Adwords or Adsense those are very
targeted ads so you don't need billions
of pageviews you just need a very
targeted audience and an advertiser
who's willing to pay a very significant
cost per thousand or a cost per click
rate because you have a targeted
audience so those are the two ways to
look at ads supported its if you have a
very targeted audience where you can use
Google Adwords and and command pretty
high cost per click rates that can work
very very well if it's a CPM kind of run
of the house remnant inventory
you better have billions of pageviews to
make that work billions that's a big
number it is but you know there there
are lots of websites out there that do
have that kind of traffic and can make
that work and that aren't solely ad
supported like ad supported is one of
the revenue streams and you know it can
be significant
so you need to look at your product your
users your audience to see whether ad
supported will work as the sole revenue
source or as one component of it so when
I see ads all over the internet a lot of
that is just people generating
incremental revenue on top of right
otherwise yeah typically it's a nice way
to have an incremental revenue source
but it's not what their whole business
is predicated on so it's a nice little
revenue stream but probably not going to
make you rich
right thanks dawn thank you Michael Bay
I hope that answers your question
if anyone else if you have questions
please add them in our YouTube comments
we love questions and we'll pick them up
in future episodes also if you're a
cloud developer and you want to run your
stuff on Google's infrastructure there
is an offer now if your root access
viewers check the information on the
screen you can sign up and get $2,000
worth of free use of the Google cloud
platform to get you started and that's
it for today see you next time